foreign
[Music]
what's on your mind today like I want to
change but I'm not particularly open to
make those changes I'm trying every time
I get rid of one compulsion another
compulsion comes up are you yawning
Right Now spoiler alert I feel like I'm
stuck
right how does that make you feel
Jimmy Liz hey it's three in the morning
I'm sorry what's in that bowl pretzels
the other Bowl maybe some painkillers
maybe there's painkillers in there yeah
I have to ask is this you forever
I don't know
[Music]
oh Hank Paul I'm worried about you good
I mean grieving here
stop you're doing sad face this is just
face
I have resting dead white face
he just kept on going on and on about
how dumb I am but he loves me
your husband is emotionally abusive he's
not working on it he doesn't intend to
just leave him
okay
I think I can help people if I get my
hands a little bit dirtier my mom wanted
you to scatter her ashes right we know
what they should do don't you ever want
to just shake them well we don't shake
them I take that back run huh it sounds
so unethical you're just gonna burn down
your career and take me with you
coin flip get out of here
this is my office it took you longer
than it should have my patients are
really thriving this thing I'm doing is
really working I'm right behind you
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody gets through this life unscathed
I can't remember mom's laugh I could
feel her slipping away
your face with a choice you're gonna let
your grief drown you or are you gonna
face it come through the other side
you sparked back
you know the cops will probably just
take it back to my house for me it must
be nice
[Applause]
[Music]
Derek how's it going just walk on the
dog I didn't want my patient moved into
her sister's house sounds like the day's
off to a great start for both of us
foreign
[Music]